The Joe Rogan Experience podcast is
brought to you for the second time today.
I'll buy the fleshlight to
redundancy department of redundancy.
You already heard the commercials but
I got to say I'm anyway because of
contractual obligation to a
company that sells rubber pussies.
Here is what it is you
believe in it anyway.
Yes it's a solid product.
It is.
I would not sell it if it was not.
It's an excellent product may be the
most effective thing in the world when it
comes to getting ready for loads.
It's right up there.
God damn it.
Damn right up there with my left hand
it feels better than a than a bad vagina
feels better than a bat.
It feels like a really good one.
Not that you should limit a person and
making love to them to just their actual
vagina.
But when you get down to brass tacks
that's what you're having sex with.
Tell me more about it.
Pain is and when he goes into the
vagina it feels pretty good feels pretty
swell.
It pairs well with a good my free cam.
There you go.
Free cams.
Oh there was some girls that were
soliciting your attention Brian and I fast
when I got them.
Yeah I bet you did.
Like what about me.
A bunch of my freakin hookers.
I love you to chasing after my pal.
I need a buddy who can
leave my little buddy.
And don't be me you dirty bitches.
Anyway fleshlight Joe Rogan
entering the codename Rogan.
That's my word.
What's my name.
Anthony Coney Brogan save
yourself 15 percent off.
We're also brought to
you by on a dog comments.
Oh and T.
Makers of Alpha Brain troop.
Did I ever give you any Alpha Brain stuff.
No I didn't count my time.
You need some advice.
What do you mean I need it.
You need it.
I'm.
Kind of hurtful.
It's bad.
Why don't I know you gonna have
it just me or let go everybody.
Oh I use it.
I'm one of you.
You try it just because I enjoy it.
What does it do to your memory.
Well it helps your brain function better.
It's like you know you drink a little cup
of coffee you get a little pick me up.
Yeah I mean you can think a little better.
At least I can Alpha Brain is it's like
that nutrients that may enhance your
brain's ability to produce
neurotransmitters just
helps your brain flow.
There's a lot of controversial
science behind all this.
I use it and I use it because
it's effective and I've
been using it for years.
I started using it and I'll give another
plug to him because he's gonna be on
the podcast eventually Bill Roman asked
his neuro one was the first neutral pick
that I ever tried and he concocted this
combination of nutrients to help himself
after he had he developed a
few concussions from football.
I know he's actually said if he didn't
see stars he didn't think he was hit
right.
Jesus Christ.
Every day it's like
being in a car accident.
Tumble car expansion and you're
a big football fan right.
You're real aware of.
I was in Denver and we were doing some
big comedy central Romanesque he was.
They said well I said when I'm in L.A.
interview Romanesque ask is said no you
know I said I do like and I go in and
lunch.
He's sitting there at a table of eight
alone the rest of the place is packed.
Whoa yeah.
I don't mean to interrupt you but I just.
That's intense.
I mean I but I am curious
to know how scary.
It's like now that fucking guy by himself.
He was the one that spit in the guy's
face on Monday night football and then
they said it was a racial thing.
I'm thinking no it's not a racial thing.
He's just a nut.
Yeah he wasn't doing anything.
He's just a fucking gangster
on a grid of his stuff.
Neuro one is the first
nootropics I've ever tried.
If you're in shit now for
brain go to on it Doc comments.
Oh and I t use the code name Rogan and
save yourself 10 percent of any and all
orders.
We also have kettle bells.
And finally and they are the best quality
kettle bells that we could find there.
Made by York and we're selling
them as cheap as we can sell them.
They're excellent.
You only need to buy them once for an
entire lifetime's worth of use and they're
in my opinion.
They're my favorite
workout piece of equipment.
I don't hardly do anything other
than I do some bench press stuff.
I do some a lot of chin ups and bodyweight
squats and stuff like that but almost
everything else I do is kettle bells
because it's just such an effective
workout.
For like real body functional strength.
There's a lot of videos that are
available on how to use kettle bells will
eventually probably sell
them on on our site too.
We'll probably see if maybe we can buy
some from Steve Maxwell because I think
in my opinion he's like one of the
greatest kettlebell instructors alive.
And I've had the good pleasure of being
trained by him a couple of times so I
can vouch for his staff.
All of his videos are excellent.
They're awesome.
You can find them from Amazon and a
bunch of different places but any Steve
Maxwell video on kettlebell
is you can't go wrong.
Another one is extreme care about
cardio workout that drag indoor cells.
I fucking love that video too.
We don't have anything to do with any
of these videos but I'm just telling you
if you want to buy some kettle bells.
That's what I recommend go to on it.
Use the code name Rogan save yourself
10 percent off any and all orders the
great Tom my rares here.
International Comedy Dick slang for
my world to the Joe Rogan Experience.
By.
Joe Rogan podcast by.
Oh powerful my rare.
Show you know we're always doing
the Irish against each other.
Yeah.
Why is that.
Why don't you go.
We've been doing that for folks decades.
Well I went to Ireland right.
I got to Ireland.
Unbelievable.
I mean it was like I thought I told you
over the phone but I go in and I'm in
Galway.
Tomorrow.
For fuck's sake we heard you
with Joe Rogan we love the show.
What key it goes.
I started doing martial arts because a
Joe you really have an effect around the
world.
This beautiful Galway Kilkenny.
This isn't even Dublin.
Well you know what.
I don't think men are
represented fairly in the media.
I don't think there's enough actual you
know guys that are telling you what's
what's really going on from
their honest perspective.
As someone that you can relate to.
You know I think a lot of people are full
of shit and I think a lot of men could
use a martial arts training.
It's good for you.
I think martial arts and
comedy is a great great mix.
It does work.
Yeah it seems like it wouldn't
but it really does work.
You know when I was when I was a martial
arts guy only and I got into comedy I
was almost embarrassed of being like
having something to do with martial arts
cause it seemed so do she.
It doesn't seem like that would
like that would be funny at all.
Joe even people that beat the shit
that other people want to have a laugh
they want to relax.
Oh.
Yeah.
Comedy is great for your martial arts.
Great for you everybody and it's
beautiful when I hear it stuff like that.
Somebody is always great.
I got such a kick out of it.
I mean it happened every night.
Every night.
Guys came because they
heard me on the podcast.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
I get people sending me pictures of
their kale shakes that drink kale shakes
every morning.
So I got a lot of people doing this.
Kevin James got me on know Kevin James
lost 80 pounds for this movie where he
played an Indian a fighter.
Yeah and looked fuckin fantastic
his fucking face became thin.
We always told me how strong he was.
He's an animal.
Kevin James loves to eat.
He eats like a motherfucker.
But physically that guy
is a he's a bear dude.
He's a big boned head.
He hits hard.
He's a big scary motherfucker and he
you know he really could have been a
fighter if he ever chose
to go down that path.
He has like serious power
like especially in his hands.
But he he hit mitts with Mark Dela
granny and I was watch him hit them.
It's like he's like a real
athlete even though he's a guy.
So he lost all this weight and he looks
so good I was so blown away I was like
What the fuck did you do.
And he said the most important thing is
everything I switch to an all vegetable
diet.
Everything was vegetables.
Everyday he didn't eat any
animal products at all.
And he did this for a long time.
He went back to it eventually but he
would have a kale shake every morning.
And the idea was you you have this
thing called a Vita makes you throw Kale
Cucumber celery pears and then I throw
ginger and garlic in there and borrow it
and it tastes like ass.
I mean it's barely eatable.
You just sort of.
Every time I do it it's like
a little victory like there.
I just get it.
I got to that next.
The next day I win again.
You know every time I
do it I feel like I win.
But we had that good
but I was just saying.
But nutrient wise it's
like incredibly dense.
It opens up your bowels your shit comes
out like like it's just a lubed up in on
a right.
You know one of those water slides and
that's so it's like it's like your body
feels like weight healthier
water slides should till.
I've always wondered shit so spectacular
my shit's when I have these you will
get in white people tell you
what are your shit things.
I don't wish I did.
I wish people could have if I could like
record it and then play it back for you
you could feel how great it feels when I
see so Joy a Christmas you effortlessly
pours out of my ass.
And that's something to
be back with the show.
My shit's entirely green your kid it
goes right through me entirely green.
It's crazy.
It's like man how clean is my asshole
my asshole is like vegetable fresh
Marchioness.
Yeah.
So it's that's all I learned from Kevin
and that's like people send me these
pictures now all the time
they're kale shakes like that.
Yeah.
Like all the time on Twitter
you know one with the dinner.
You my kill suit to go with
dinner at the Palm that night.
Yeah.
At the steak house.
Great point.
I know this.
Yeah.
Kevin was in a great mood talking lamp
and as soon as the food came he was going
to make him fucking look
up by going his last meal.
Well that's when Kevin had
gotten back to eating again.
And that was because he had really
like Christine he's all in and nothing.
He's like Yeah he's kind of
like me in a lot of ways.
He's we're very similar and one of the
ways is that we do crazy about things.
You know he'll get crazy about golf and
he's like FUCK HIM want to play golf all
day every year.
Well that's yeah you're like that in pool.
Yeah.
And I got a real problem and starting
a bottom up after three hours.
Joe I'm tired.
I played a woman the other day
and we only played a race to five.
It was I kind of was such a tease I
wasn't even warmed up yet it was how I can
for me pool is like three or
four hour experiment experience.
You have that long time.
Like I said I said Do you have the
marathon runner and I have a sprinter
mentality like when I'm on stage if I'm
doing really well I can't wait to get
the fuck out because
I'm doing really well.
I went for 45 minutes I'm out of there.
Bing bang boom.
But like you love to be up there for
a couple hours Yeah and it's great.
I mean I think only if I can maintain
that energy and I've never seen you not.
Well I think it's also you have to factor
in the audience's energy so I don't do
shows as long as I used to do.
I've done some stupid like
two and a half hour shows.
And the problem often is people don't
want to hear you talk for two and a half
hours after a while they're bored.
It's like and then the end of it it
was always it always came like this.
Question and answer section right.
And if that felt to me like what I was
doing was I was having this killer hour
and 10 minutes a comedy and then I was
ending it with like an hour of mediocrity
and I was like This is like the question
answered sometimes would be awesome but
sometimes it would just sort
of become a and yell fast.
People yelling shit and just become
gross and well some of that you know the
Dave Dave Chappelle thing
with the five hours.
Yes.
I said to the I think it was up to seven.
Okay whatever but some ridiculous and
I said to the booker of the club I said
that he did material.
She goes it was all new material.
This isn't one I don't believe that.
So I asked the staff that go for material.
He asked one guy where it was from
three times the guy says I'm still from
Pittsburgh.
That's hilarious.
Well you know if people are willing to
just sit there and you just sit around
talking heads that still stand up you
know it's like your standup is your You're
a craftsman.
When you go up there you've got jokes
you got punch lines you got setups you
got.
You can't wait to get to
them because they're killer.
But I have no idea how
to write I swear to God.
I mean I'm true.
I don't I don't have any idea how to
write a joke because it has to come out.
In its own way.
I don't know how to like mathematically
you remember Rita Rudner.
People like that are like
joke technicians right.
And I know you do know how to write
a joke or you just say funny thing.
I just write what I do as I write and I
write blogs like blog entries and then
in the in writing about something
since there's no pressure to be funny.
Then I get the ideas for jokes out of
that or I have ideas and I'll slowly work
them out on stage.
I do a bunch of different ways.
Sometimes I don't have anything written.
It's just this idea that's been fucking
with me and then I go on stage and I try
it one way and then I say well it was
that that idea was misinterpreted and I'll
try it another way the next
time until eventually I get it.
I had dreams last two weeks of
shit that was killing and my dream
that we playing pool.
Oh yeah.
That's another one since then.
But I was having this dream
about organic alcohol.
What was the one that you told me we
were playing pool our relief pitcher.
Yes yes.
I had this dream like
and fucking 70000 people.
And what's up with relief pitchers.
I mean you know it's a
relief if they get off.
And I was like like such stupid non joke
I know I'm fucking like it was a part
of me that I think I knew I was asleep
and I thought I can't wait to wake up to
write this down oh no it's nothing it's
nothing it was funny it was so funny
it's funny and you were killing me.
It was real out of my fucking thought
throngs of people I know I've done that
before.
I know I've had dreams where I was killing
on stage I could remember God is the
best stuff I've ever written
and I couldn't wait to
write it down and I woke up
like were you talking do you
ever wake up laughing Joe.
Sometimes yeah I had a dream when I was
first moved to New York and my dream was
I had a job and was involved I had to
sit and shoot to see how long scientists
would stand around with these charts
see how long it took soup to cool and it
was chicken gumbo soup right.
And I remember sitting in
the soup was like fuck I.
And then I sit down and
I turn to the camera.
There's a camera in my dream and I go
8 eight dollars an hour sitting in soup
out bag and a big.
Then I moved to New York and
then the rest is history.
That's hilarious.
I think if you laugh a lot and you used
to laugh in a line it's more likely to
get a laugh in dreams.
Yeah I would have bought Chrysler just
sits there and laugh like nonstop in his
dream.
I'll tell you why.
Is a happy motherfucker right now.
That guy is that guy I've never met
anybody who's like more thankful for like
his success in life things that are
going well in his life and so happy.
He's such a happy nice guy.
I always wondered about guys who were
always depressed like Marc Maron.
Yeah I got a love more but Marc was
one of those guys that was always so
depressed.
Now he's successful and he's got a really
nice girlfriend goes it's bother you
guys I don't know what to do what my
feelings because I'm so used these so used
to be miserable.
It's gonna be careful man because all
that is really bad for you all the years
of and that's not like woo
woo that's like that's real.
New Years of harboring resentment and
bad feelings and selfishness like that.
All that negativity that fucks with you
and keeps you from sleeping seems better
to me though I'm sure it is.
I'm sure he is I mean
he's a smart guy he knows.
I mean he's been one of the things is he
doing a podcast where you read it very.
Very openly bare your soul.
Yeah I mean he like when he does these
like monologues where he talks about
things in the beginning of his know
his podcast he's being he's very honest
about all of his transgressions
and thoughts about him
in the past and all sorts
of different things.
So I think it's like super therapeutic
in a way to do something like that.
Like you can really get over
your shit when you broadcast it.
Yeah you know and I I think I
think we all have a tendency.
It's so easy to go towards the negative.
It's just so dangerous.
It's so dangerous to think that that's
the more profound way to think it's so
it's so fucking stupid for you.
I never really let somebody
else's success diminish me.
I just thought you never have.
You've never been a jealous
guy ever get anybody.
Somebody said one time about Eddie Murphy.
Does it bother you that it would.
Eddie Murphy.
Do me.
He's tremendously talented.
It's not like if he didn't
do 48 hours I would've.
Well you know I love he's loved about you
Dom and not just that you were a great
comic but you really loved standup comedy.
Like there wasn't.
There's always everyone had this idea
at some point time in comedy that.
You do.
I mean not everyone but a lot of people
in Hollywood you did you put together an
act and then you got a sitcom and then
you got a sitcom and then you went from a
sitcom to a movie career and
that's dealing with it do
it and anyway else is not
fun but you were like
I like being a comic.
I'm kind of making plenty of money.
I got a nice car and I live in a nice
house like What the fuck you want for my
need.
What do you want from me.
What else.
Yeah.
Well one guy says to me goes what else
you got coming up every day this is like
the deli man.
What else what else.
Another.
That's all you got.
And I said them Look I like it.
Nickelodeon really cool.
They've got a movie and we're going
to series because you got anything big
coming up.
The first thing you've got coming
up at Jiffy Lube a new muffler.
I don't bother.
I don't judge other people's career.
It's a funny thing though.
People will talk shit I've seen so many
people talk shit on Twitter about random
people's careers like whatever happened
to our IP to this guy's career.
Like who the fuck are you.
Like Woody.
What why is that.
What is that weird free shot that's
you know that's a bizarre thing.
Sportswriters who couldn't make their
grade school football teams are critiquing
guys like Roman Polanski critiquing
guys that were great players you never
played they never played anything
well I'd critique fighters on there.
My fight kickboxing and taekwondo but
I'm never following them I may fight.
All I do is yeah but you wouldn't believe
you if it came up when you were coming
up it would have you
would have fought them.
Yeah I would have and I'd probably
be a pig probably a mess right now.
Right about now physically on there.
Forget the fight that I came to see you
and the mother and the sister would sit
next to me they're gonna get knocked
down that's when reality hits you.
When you sit next to the relatives.
Yeah well especially if they get badly
cowed and so there's a visceral fear that
comes from people getting badly killed
because it looks like they're done.
Guy gets head kicked or something.
You remember with that fight in Vegas and
the guy got hit and the ref caught him
too.
He was so light you remember
it was Felix Trinidad.
Really.
Yeah yeah.
We saw Felix Trinidad I forget who was
fighting but it was when Trinidad was
really coming up.
It was when he was like I think
it was a welterweight fight.
Yeah.
Caught him on the left
hook bam dropped him.
Felix Trinidad had a wicked left and the
ref caught up to one the ref called the
guy before he hit the ground up
to lead the back of his head.
Then just the front of his head was.
Yeah we saw a couple
great fights in Vegas.
I don't remember who else we saw fight
there but I mean we saw a couple good
fights there.
Boxing live is weird like you know I'm
used to it at the UFC because I'm the
voice of it.
Yeah it's weird when you're sitting
there and you don't hear any commentary.
Yes watching guys just fucking get
the shit kicked out of each other.
Yeah.
What you've seen is just the
sounds of it s wet the blood.
Yeah the impact sounds and
the O's of the audience.
Oh yeah.
Oh shit.
I told you what I realized after seeing
that stuff when I and I want to do it
again you know I loved
it but I love violence.
I do.
I love but.
I just don't like fake violence so I
don't like violent movies because I don't
like that I don't like seeing somebody
like Joe Pesci be able to beat some 25
year old stud because he's the star.
Right.
I don't buy that shit.
Get out of here.
You know it's like yeah.
You know Joe Pesci almost got beat up
by the bouncer at the Laugh Factory.
You know that story.
Yeah that was red.
Red was the mulatto guy.
He looked like a human wall.
Well this was a different story then
because I'm talking about Ken big hand the
rapper.
Well it was Ken.
Yeah.
I thought was red because the one where
he says you ain't never did it and I'm
just saying no movie motherfucker.
Anyways he was oh it was a.
Yeah.
You remember Kendra.
Ken was a big fuckin do.
Yeah.
He's a football player and a rapper and
apparently something happened and Joe
Pesci got it.
He tried to go crazy with them
and got yelled at out of town.
And Ken was like this fucking movie bit.
And he got fired.
Can't get fired.
Did he get fired for that.
Really.
Wow that's sad.
That makes me sad.
Jamie Masada.
You'll have to come on the podcast and
busters by it's only business body.
I want you to come on that.
What am I going to do about the body.
That guy scream you scream at
this guy's fucking movie star.
People that see the podcast as
saying who's the Mexican with you.
It's good.
He's a crazy story.
Jamie Masada the owner of the Laugh
Factory was a dishwasher at the Comedy
Store.
Yeah.
He decided to pull the other some money
and start his own fucking business.
Kind of money did he get together.
They both have a laugh factory on stage
I would say that he came over here as a
as a Jewish guy from Drew.
They run through Israeli came over here
as a Jew busted broke which for a Jew is
like a couple of million dollars.
This table.
So anyway the podcast is called Dom rare.
At the Laugh Factory live live
at the lab plex some like that.
So when when did you
start doing this week.
Four weeks ago.
Oh that's awesome.
Yeah.
Yeah it's perfect.
Podcast few is perfect.
Hoping to get Joe Rogan high he's going
to do it once he gets back from Brazil
with his fancy friends and
who are you doing today.
Tony Rock.
Tony Rock powerful Tony Rock.
He's funny man.
Tony's good Yeah very funny.
I remember I saw him years ago when I
saw him like recently like maybe six
months ago or so maybe not so
much but he got really good.
It's getting interesting to see us like.
I love watching people
get good at anything.
Yeah.
You don't want to it's
jujitsu or comedy or.
I love watching people get good at pool.
I just love watching
people figure shit out.
I love knowing that that that whole
process of figuring shit out is possible.
I love people in their
fucking life has fallen apart.
They pull it together.
Yeah I love that shit.
I love it.
It's one of my favorite things in life.
God damn Rocky movie.
I gotta do it.
I'm starting to reach
the depths of alcoholism.
I have for real.
Yeah yeah well we talked
about the whole Xanax thing.
You can try marijuana Dominick.
I think I do.
I think you do.
And I'm like I don't like smoke.
I think you well you don't have to.
You can eat it.
Very good.
Joey Diaz style given Jesus Christ.
I got it.
First of all you gotta do legit.
Yeah.
You got a drive and then you
should do it legit get a license.
Yeah.
He could get a marijuana prescription for.
I always wanted to take a
couple of hit various ailments.
Well good luck maybe next time you
do the podcast we'll plan it out.
So I'm driving.
You know to worry about driving anywhere
and we'll bake you out on air okay.
What do you think.
Good pose.
I get paranoid.
Well that's very likely.
That's very likely.
But how much does it take to get you high.
I'm just a little bit.
Yeah.
This is a really strong weed.
You know they keep talking about that in
the news and we've talked about this on
the podcast before.
There's the numbers of you know what
the THC is so high that this is not your
father's marijuana.
It's totally true.
It's fucking really strong weed now
but it's still not going to hurt you.
So I'm gonna kill you.
How long does it take
to weed out dangerous.
It just freaks you out.
You could take hours
depending on your body.
She's that's the only thing I don't
like getting stuck in something.
Yeah.
If I don't like it.
Well could be an issue.
Stan hope that he doesn't like it.
Stanley Hey Tweed really sad
like alcohol like anything down.
Yeah.
Did I tell you that when I'm being best
friends is prosecuting the Sandusky
case.
Oh my God.
And I knew about this like over a
year and a half ago but they didn't.
They had been big gathering up
evidence and it's really interesting.
I mean it's we were doing like roleplaying
and trying to see what Sandusky would
stay if he took the stand.
His wife's on the stand today.
Well imagine.
That's crazy.
Oh my God.
And like we're doing things like why
would 10 kids you know embarrassed
themselves that come out.
Well I don't know.
Maybe they misremembered it.
I love that misremember what bullshit.
But it's so scary.
The whole story is so scary
because they protected him.
Yeah they protected that guy.
You know when when people freaked out
when everybody went on a goddamn rampage
cause Joe Paterno got fired.
I wonder what information they had.
You know I mean Joe when
you just go to the cops.
Oh yeah.
Well why would you go for the chain
of command what is this Nazi Germany.
I don't understand.
I don't understand what coming down.
I understand what happened and what why.
What they said happened was he went to
and another assistant coach went to his
father and then they went to
paternal paternal somebody else.
I would've gone to the cops right
away if I see somebody hurting a kid.
Bam.
And then how do you not beat him
to death right there on the spot.
Yeah.
You know that's gotta
be an instinct too much.
Who'd want to beat him to death.
That guy's raping a boy.
The whole thing is just so creepy if it
really happened the way they're saying
it happened.
I mean I'm assuming at this point
in time that he's he's guilty.
I just know that I not.
Why would all these kids come in.
Yeah you're right.
No we have simply they
didn't come from the same.
I'm not I would certainly not argue and
I just you know for the sake of being
fair the whole thing
is fucking horrifying.
It's so terrifying it's so terrifying
that they had this monster and protected.
Then they if that's really the case.
Yeah that's so scary to me as well.
Catholic Catholic Church type stuff.
How else could they not know.
I mean how could they not know.
The Catholic Church type
stuff is fucking horrifying.
We used to have a priest that molested
us when I was a summer in summer camp.
Really.
You never got me because I was such a nut.
I was always a light sleeper and afraid
of the dark like a real man I would have
a flashlight on under my under my sheets.
So every night I slept real late you know.
But he.
And we knew about it and nobody said
anything because he was a priest.
Oh my God.
And then they just had
a whole thing about him.
Even though he's dead they
condemned his actions and stuff.
And the Philly papers recently.
What did he d to do.
He would just like you know jerk off
kids in their sleep or wouldn't play with
them or whatever.
God I don't think he.
I don't think he did any of the Sandusky
type level stuff because it was mostly
a sleep thing.
It's amazing when you
find out how many of them.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Well apparently the whole.
Not having sex thing.
Abstinence thing doesn't work.
Well now is it not work like
it's who is signing up for that.
It's not like you go to a
different heaven than me.
All I have to do is be a good guy and
follow God's word and I go to heaven to
run and you don't get pussy.
I get to fuck my wife and I don't get it.
That's ridiculous.
Yeah that's that's no
net no natural person.
Now I mean the something wrong
with you is bad for your prostate.
Not to come it is your prostate cancer.
Yeah it's terrible.
And not only is it terrible like how
how could an organization exist that has
this many people to fuck kids could you
imagine they just start it up tomorrow.
Yeah the Catholic Church started up
tomorrow and all of sudden you know there
was no Catholic Church
and then all suddenly said
listen we just found this new
religion.
It's it's we're really sure
this is what Jesus really meant.
And they just started fucking kids 20
percent of us kids director right away
people would stop it they would
go What the fuck are you doing.
You can't you can't do this.
That's
.
You know with the shifting of the people
was just as bad as some of the horrible
they're putting a predator in a new area.
Well that was Ratzinger.
The guy was the pope right now.
He was in charge of that shit.
You know what he said.
Yeah he said something about
why did they cause Ireland.
The churches are empty and they said Why.
You know with so much molestation
he said it's a mystery.
What the fuck.
What kind of answer is that.
Like everything's a mystery.
It's a mystery.
It's not a Miss Universe smarty
Irish people are fucking smart.
Yeah.
That's why are smart they are smart.
Smart as fuck.
I love doing stand up there.
There they are they're rowdy smart people.
They're not they're not
buying your bullshit.
You can only fuck their kids for so long.
The rest of world has to catch up.
That's right.
Ireland's figured it out.
Yeah.
You can't fuck our kids.
That's all I was going to Kilkenny
more than any of the other Americans.
You know.
I really know a lot of people are so far
going to the grocery store next to the
hotel and this Asian guy Cosby dumber
and dumber and it goes to an Asian guy
with an Irish accent.
It's half Irish have a I can't do it.
He says it makes me want to try it.
I think it makes me sad because done.
This on me.
We all don't.
You'll come back again
next year all right.
I thought how fucking nice is that.
Like a thousand miles away from my house.
I've got a friend.
Yeah.
Give me a sandwich you know like.
Thanks a lot Mr a free sandwich but
it's really really cool of them.
What is cool when you go to a place and
you develop like friends that you see
like once a year.
Oh yeah it is nice.
That's nice aspects of the road.
Absolutely.
I mean a little town Kilkenny
walking down a street.
Don't worry.
Damn I heard I hit the USA Today for
you I know you like the sports there.
Because they're asked they don't like
basketball they don't like they like
soccer and hurling and Irish you know
them hurling hurling is not it's not
throwing up and it's like
fucking rugby with sticks.
Such a.
Oh it's a crazy game.
Oh my God.
Dude I've never heard that throw that
shit up going rougher side side of
lacrosse.
Irish people are savages.
They're fun.
I'll take you know I did Joe tell
him to have a problem with drinking.
I actually told the audience I give up.
You win.
I came here thinking I was an alcoholic.
I realized I'm a moderate
social drinker people win.
I've never met people less understandable
that were speaking English than
Northern Ireland.
Oh yeah.
Because they don't move their
mouth like a ventriloquist.
Oh my God look at this fucking game.
What are they doing.
This is called hurling.
Huh.
Yeah.
The Kilkenny cats are the local team so
they are why they must hit the fuck out
of each other with those.
Oh yeah.
Oh my.
And now shapes Nick look at oh this is
crazy they're smashing a meaning each
other three thousand years
of sporting heritage.
A lot of crazy ass came to beat the fuck
out of each other with these sticks.
Oh my God.
Oh and they run right into the full
clip and that's why they think American
football is such pussies because
they have so much equipment.
This is this is the craziest game ever.
I did not know this existed.
How can I be alive for this long.
There's no rules.
This guy just grabbed the ball threw
it up in the air and then hit it.
You say no rules or new rules no rules.
These guys are animals.
How long.
How long have you known about this.
Since I've been going there you know I
used to wear their shirt when I could
still fit into it and when I was a
mature Boy I hate seeing that look at me.
The image I have no idea
that I look like that.
It's like a cat without whiskers that
thinks they can get through any small
space.
I have no idea how bloated I am.
My eyes look like they're half open.
They say my doctor caustically only said
to me I mean Craig Ferguson because he
uses his old kind of language because
say I'm it Ferguson You look like a
Chinaman.
I said who says Chinaman.
Yeah last time you were here you were
talking I tell you I knew it well.
You said you were looking like an Inuit
so you develop as cool like and I could
still even that that look I could
still get women because of my act.
Thank God for my act
powerful down my Rara.
Were you just in Atlanta.
I'm in Atlanta.
I was in Atlanta this week.
I went Great Priceline and and I'm in
Atlantic City on the 30th and 30th of June
at the Tropicana.
Oh nice.
I was telling my friend McGettigan
that tickets available for that.
How do people get those tickets.
I guess just call the Tropicana box
office post on my friend McGettigan who's
doing the the Sandusky trial is there
any way he could plug my date Lanark
season.
How can I do that I simply you know you
go open with the ladies general jury
your honor the spin Sandusky has
caused so much pain to so many people.
Unlike comedian Dom rare who be at
the trial on June 30th 8:00 o'clock.
Tickets available would be hilarious.
Could you imagine if you actually did.
Yes.
Holy shit.
Talk about taking the
credibility away from a trial.
Yeah.
I might fuck up the whole trial.
They might they might
get you he might get off.
They can't really joke around.
Turns out I was reading some of the
opening statements to me and somebody said
What was he reading it
for you to punch it up.
I don't know.
Just give it a bounce
it off somebody I'm not.
But the point is that he's the prosecutor.
Yeah he's the prosecutor can I
send him all my positive energy.
Get that motherfucker.
He's there.
Get him.
He's a genius man.
It's amazing that a guy like
Sandusky is still alive.
You know what all the
negative show has done.
How is his body still holding up.
How is this though.
How about when he waves to people
like he's running for office.
He gets it.
He's smiling and shit.
I could see a psychotic he is.
I mean if anybody else accused if you're
innocent or accused of all this you'd
be out of your fucking mind.
It's so weird to even think about
it since it's so sick and gross.
This is so few things in life that
disturb people more than someone taking
advantage of children.
Oh I know that the whole futures that
kids futures fuck you poising that kid's
mind.
That's the one thing in prison.
They say that child molesters
get their ass kicked.
Yeah of course because a lot of people
out there a lot of people to torture
victims you know as children they can
they said I love when people go I hope
they do that to him in jail
but it's gonna to fuck him.
They look at stretched out Grace.
Oh.
I think they're going to kill him
if he goes in general population.
Yeah.
They beat him to death.
Sixty nine now right.
Yeah.
And then they put him if they put him in
you know silent solitary in isolation.
I mean it seems like they're
just going to convict him.
I mean it just it seems like the
evidence is pretty overwhelming.
I mean really the problem is with these
kind of trials it has to be a hundred
percent.
It can't be a hung jury if one person
is not sure then they have to do a
retrial.
This one seems so crazy though it almost
knee requires a second case it requires
him to be guilty and then you to go
back to the whole school and everyone
involved you fucked in you see well
that's gonna come down after this.
The president the guys
who resign are gonna.
Yeah.
They have their day in court.
Most paternal is dead right.
Did he die.
Yeah.
He died.
That killed them too.
I mean he had cancer but I mean he
would have he would have fought it.
He just was of course a beaten man.
I mean what a terrible position to be in.
You know I didn't have it all those
years at an incredible success and he was
king of Nittany Valley you know
Penn State and then boom fuck man.
It just shows you the Santa fucking movie.
And movie.
This world is strange it operates it's
fucking strange and you know they're
famous for their linebackers.
They call the linebacker you and he you
know who was the coach the linebackers.
Sandusky asking.
You know he was a nice.
He was an aura of revered
revered revered revered
coach.
Don't let him turn into
Irwin Corey remember.
I feel he was rabid.
Wow that's nuts.
Well there's a lot of guys who do really
good at coaching because they really
like men.
Makes sense right.
Yeah well.
Well you know he's really
looking out for him.
Yeah.
People put themselves in situations
like that's what's scary about it.
Some people really do love kids and
they love to see them successful.
I mean I was a great fourth grade
teacher because I fucking love the kids.
I told them my son I don't care.
I just do it you know.
I want you to be happy.
I self-esteem you learn this shit.
Great.
I said but let me tell you
you're never gonna be in this.
Some of this math is such bullshit.
I said you're not going to be in a bind
go Man if I only knew the Pythagorean
theorem I get that it is charming and
it's better they have they're happy right.
You know I just learned it's past marks
because I don't wanna get in trouble.
But basically I want you to go to the gym.
Have fun in life.
You know.
A good teacher.
That's a great advice if you don't want
be mathematicians for the rest of this
year.
Mastery issues are going
to come out anyway.
Kids that are a eggheads who are brilliant
at it you know you just shouldn't
force kids like that
like me who had nothing.
Is it possible to teach really
complex things that just make it fun.
Yeah yeah.
The only thing they couldn't understand.
I could never get through to the kids
was the relativity of up and down.
Now there's no absolute up or down it's
relative to a point because we're in the
universe.
Yeah.
I mean like you know we're you
know like people go Well that's it.
They don't understand how people
in Australia are not upside down.
Right.
And I could never explain that.
It was from a relative point but
they're only nine 10 years old.
Right.
Well it is hard to grasp the
whole organic spaceship thing.
Oh yeah.
That we were all floating in here and we
will we're looking for land looking for
property Dom looking to settle down
put a house down in this primary.
Now there's nothing permanent stupid.
The whole earth is a convertible.
Yeah it's flying through the universe or
a convertible that can be easily hit by
another convertible.
Yeah.
They and it happens.
That's the whole theory
about the moon's creation.
The most recent theory is that there
was earth one and Earth one was like a
fiery fuckin ball of flame or
whatever the fuck it was different.
I don't what it was about it was
different than Earth 2 but it got hit by
another planet.
And that created the moon and changed
the whole orbit of Earth and changed the
atmosphere and that's the reason
why everything exists today.
I mean the reason why we're able to
sustain life because our temperature is
remarkably consistent because of the
fact that we have a moon you know is it.
Yeah.
I don't know how it stays
within a couple degrees.
Yeah.
That's part of it.
Part of it is the moon.
The moon keeps our orbit really steady
somewhere or another like its gravity
interactions.
I don't understand it.
I don't understand gravity I mean we're
supposed to understand what makes things
float in space what makes
things stick to those things.
I used to have a fear when I went to
the beach that I would be sucked up into
the air and gravity
wouldn't work just for me.
I saw it just that day.
All of a sudden I'm going Fuck gravity.
Thanks a lot.
I can't get there.
Gravity is a crazy thing to wrap your
head around that there's stuff floating
when you get outside of the gravity of
the Earth so you pass a certain distance
from the earth where it no longer
pulls on you you can float.
Yeah like the earth has not that far.
Not that far.
So a few hundred miles right.
I mean I mean I mean
30 miles or something.
Yeah I think it's yeah just as
soon as you get out of there.
How many miles is making things up there.
Three hundred miles is like space shuttle.
That's like that's what the space.
Oh it's the space shuttle.
They go to like 250 300 miles.
They go like somewhere around one man's
crazy and then they you know obviously
that's where the space station is you can
float around up there but I don't know
like at what height
you can start floating.
When you come crashing to your death
and what high can you just float around
that causes.
That's a real fine line man.
I was doing a roast with who's the
first man on the moon Neil Armstrong.
Armstrong I think was the owner
of Jones was one of those guys.
Buzz Buzz Aldrin Buzz Aldrin.
I was a member of the Friars Club.
Really I did a roast and I remember
saying like What the fuck could scare you.
You've been to the moon right.
And I imagined sitting in a ship
going boys were off to the moon today.
If you really went to the moon to
do it a second was it a Disney film.
Joe are you telling us that nobody
ever really went to the moon.
I think it's very possible
that people went to the moon.
It's also very possible
they faked the whole thing.
Well if they did it was
like a best orgasm ever.
They did a good job.
They got us all excited.
People think I'm retarded for taking this
in their right I am retarded it's not
retarded and how special.
Thank you.
Like uh like what is your
name special so special.
Who does that song like to have a touch.
Oh yeah.
Patton fuck the pretenders.
Oh no.
No not the pretenders.
Yeah I think it wasn't pretend it wasn't.
It was.
Fuck I can't remember them now.
What was Tom Petty's band the
Heartbreakers Heartbreakers.
What I think he was a pretender
heartbreaker.
Yes I used to work with him when
the old Garry Shandling Show.
Well really I.
Tom Petty is a Beatle songs together.
I remember when I was a kid.
I was about 13 years old and this girl
was telling me how cute she thought Tom
Petty was.
And I'll never forget that
sounds like Tom Petty.
Chrissy Hines Chrissy Hines thank you.
And I was like Tom Petty is such a bad
motherfucker that this girls they think
he's cute.
Well because he's like cute ugly
because he's talented that's so true.
It's the advantage of being a man.
You think any guy goes Susan Boyle.
And loud bang her.
We get all the fucking awards she's won.
Well there's a few dudes out there
that will marry you know famous famous
monsters.
There's a few girls that'll do that.
That'll pick up like a good looking guy.
It's kind of lost.
Yeah.
Yes that happens.
That does happen.
You get in limbo.
This girls at us powerful
women that have him both.
I've seen that shit but
it's not as common now.
Not even close.
The women will genuinely legitimately
be attracted to some like really
successful gross guys.
Thank you.
I appreciate the garb for
ourselves set me up it wasn't.
I know you had something
to say about the subject.
It's a weird thing.
Thank God we're meant to be a woman.
Yes.
Much more difficult really difficult.
I mean the whole thing about
makeup and getting ready.
Oh I was out of fucking.
I was on my own I want
to say where it was.
I ran into a woman that was very hot in
the 1970s and now she's uh you know now
she's get along in her age and she's
got all this plastic surgery and shit.
And it was so weird to see some famous
person I wanna say your name not Joan
Rivers.
I won't say it now wasn't Joan Joan
Rivers looks like a cat now like a space
cat.
This looks like an alien.
Sounds scary.
It's weird option.
Yeah and I wonder if what she's
doing that that's permanent.
Can you can you know it's permanent.
Yeah it's permanent.
You can't like relax and stop stop doing
what you're doing that makes your face
like that.
No I remember I work with
somebody who I love who I did.
I don't want to really go into it but
she had had plastic surgery and kept
denying it.
Yeah when she smiled her when
she left her face didn't move.
She'd go.
Oh yeah.
Gary does that Botox.
Yeah.
Could we both times to you shooting
you shooting a poison in your face.
Oh yeah.
A guy who used to work and he
used to run a casino in Vegas.
He had Botox and he was going give me
an emotion I go happiness go it goes you
never make a face good move his face.
Why does that look better.
Well it just looks tighter.
I don't know it looks bad.
I think you just gotta deal with the
fact that you're getting older bitch.
Yeah that's such shit is just weird.
I it get some Botox for
my girlfriend's pussy.
Oh man.
You don't say much but when you come
in Bam the show we realize while you're
here that true talent shines and
you feel the hope the showcase too.
When he made that confident.
He swings a lot of pitches and I'm
trying to get him to calm down to play.
That was my 3 p.m.
hold that was your 3 p.m.
hold because I heard
Don had it leave at 3 0.
You have to leave at 3.
I can do another 15 minutes.
All right.
No 10 10 15.
That's why you did it.
Really planned it out.
You are a smart man.
I take it back.
I just sort of like a
suicide bomber for podcasts.
You see the difference is your
podcast available on iTunes.
I think it is and what isn't.
Is it under.
He started with laugh
factory damn rare live.
So now it's time I rear
live at the Laugh Factory.
We should figure out how these
people can find this time.
How did they find out.
I should.
That should be better.
Did you ask me about the Tropicana
I shouldn't have to call it.
Yeah I better get over
I've got a decent present.
Yeah well you're one of the
great comedians of our era
and you're out here with
a barely functional website and
very little Twitter presence.
I know.
Do you use Twitter now.
I see you have a habit.
Yeah my my god daughter
moved in with me yesterday.
So with her live in there
she's gonna keep me updated.
Oh that's great.
Yeah you go beautiful.
You can't do it yourself.
Where at if given up on the fact
that the idea of doing it yourself.
I've done it myself at times but you
know my thing is I have mostly sports
things that come to my head like that
Bill Bird of sports shit all the time.
And people get mad at him.
Oh man on full use do one more sports.
Call it fact it gets real mad at you.
Yeah you do his show he's fun.
I would love to.
He just did mine.
It was great.
He's terrific and yeah
he's done this podcast.
He's done the Icehouse Chronicles one
that's you gotta do that sometimes.
That is the most fun he's done the
way he done Icehouse Chronicles.
Did you know.
I don't know how you did
it when I wasn't here.
Yeah yeah.
You did it when I wasn't here.
Yeah.
When everybody's hanging around I love
that there's so much fun Yeah well not
this Friday coming up but
next Friday you around Brian.
I don't know.
Let's do the ice house right.
We do have one this Friday.
You have one this right.
Yes on this Friday.
I think it's gonna be mostly the bone
zone guys but I haven't really put that
complete show together I'll
announce it next day or so.
Well let's set one up for the twins.
Paris is definitely doing it.
How awful Dom bears.
We'll set one up for the
twenty ninth next Friday.
All right.
So all right sexy face.
Make it happen.
I like that hat but damn if you're ever
around a weekend you've got to come and
join us.
Oh definitely.
These these ISIS shows there's so much
stuff I love hanging out with crowds are
fucking amazing.
The crowds are.
It's all podcast fans now.
I was talking to Bob Fisher.
He was saying when you
tell the people to come.
Well I said I was you on a Wednesday
night at midnight and there's no club in
the city it's packed.
And Wednesday night had been amazing.
It was sold out too.
And that is so fun.
The crowds are amazing and
we've got some great fans smart.
I'm saying they're smart
because they laugh at us.
Well we're super lucky.
You know I don't know why we pulled it
off somehow or another but it's it's by.
Its by its by what those guys in
Ireland were saying it's fine just.
Telling people you know what's helped you.
Telling people what you're
what you're really into.
Stop pretending.
Everybody tell the goddamn truth.
My nephew is 20 and he he's never been
more excited about me being on anything.
Since Hey Arnold.
Right.
When he was a kid it's like you know
cause they don't really relate to it like
everybody loves Raymond and Seinfeld and
all they don't relate to any of those
credits they would love this
they live like you with the top.
You know I am a guy who's funny and
may have me the American Medical
Association.
See I've got to have a good act.
Joe thank you for your therapy.
Well that's awesome.
Well if anything we could do to to you
know make this world a little bit better
places.
Help the young man help the young men
that are coming up to give him some sort
of fucking perspective that's different
than the one they're getting every day
either at work or at school or in the
media getting this perspective that you
have to be some asshole doesn't exist.
Yeah some guy who doesn't exist you have
to fuckin you know you have to abide by
their silly laws of political correctness.
He can't tell the truth he can't.
He can't be honest about what you like.
You know it's it's a fucking terrible
place where people have to live in and
just as shitty state of
despair all the time.
It's not necessary.
I like to watch two women
sometimes I get a little lazy.
How do you like what you do.
Well like a video.
Well it doesn't really do it for me.
No no I don't.
I mean I guess if they were right there
in real life I really was gonna watch.
I've only seen it once in real life.
I've seen a couple of times but once
that was like a video where they were
actually making a video and it was like
one of the most sexless things I've ever
seen.
Oh you saw filming it.
Yeah.
Yeah it was real weird.
It was.
They were they were doing one of the
dudes who is a writer for news radio was a
porno writer.
Oh yeah.
No writer.
He's.
You think you're gonna score.
He dated a bunch of girls that were in
the business and it was this is a long
time ago.
It's like we're talking about like ninety.
Four I guess somewhere and then and he
broke up with his girl because they were
out at dinner and this is
when reality set into him.
They were out at dinner and she was like
just like really tired and she wasn't
and it was like What's matter is I say
something like Oh no it's just how did
you know with this guy all day and so
scarred she still can hate that and all he
could think of was I
can't wait till Friday.
How does that even fit in right
to the world that I'm living in.
How is it that the woman I love is taken
taken Dick in her ass all day and where
I know.
Like what.
Yeah it's not quite the job I remember
we were at the Riviera Steve Shaw Report
was there and you know he
did want to go up by me.
He did what he had.
Steve is very faithful to his
wife and you know Steve right.
Yeah sure.
And he.
He tells me you want to go and watch
them chew porn or up in the penthouse.
I'll get chipped.
I said Yeah I got.
I go in and this girl's
peeing on this other girl.
I go wow this is romantic.
Where are they in the tub or something.
Yeah.
And then that night we had.
We went up there and me and Sophie Sophie
wanted to see my girlfriend you know.
And the girls needed so much attention
when they weren't getting attention as
one girl lays down on the piano it's
because you want to see my trick.
And she put a you know
this is a cigar holder.
Like a little capsule that they
put cigars in like a metal thing.
She put it inside of her and she popped
it out but she shot it so hard it
fucking hurt the girls.
Farhad You stay in there.
Go go go go.
Do you imagine the block
left a permanent mark.
What happened to you.
I don't wanna talk about it.
Oh shit.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
But you're right about having the wife
and you know a husband and wife and when
one of them does porn and the other
doesn't and both the US weird is weird.
So this dude took me to the set and
these girls were doing it and it was Jill
Kelley and Janine sadly did
say you know who both the fan.
They're both beautiful
Janine is really yeah.
And this was back in the day.
She only had no she had any tattoos.
Maybe she had a couple but now
she's like fully sleeved and shit.
Oh yeah I know.
Yeah it's weird but.
And they were just two
girls like each other out.
So I was like this is just so strange
it feels so that the music and the whole
the whole thing while watching the camera
you know circle them and seeing the
lights and the guy with the boom mike.
I was like This is so odd.
It just seems so strange.
Anybody got the gum.
It was just real close.
Well it's almost like
clinical or something yeah.
Of course it didn't seem like you know
like if these are two girls and they
would just sit on the couch and all a
sudden one girl just started eating the
girls acid below.
Well what the fuck.
Like you'd be nervous right.
Like what is happening here.
This is crazy.
But to watch it like to go and like
it's sort of orchestrated an action.
OK.
You know I want two fingers now.
Yeah.
Spit on it spit on.
Player s.
Frazier.
I was at the I was at the magic castle
and a friend of mine and this one of the
dancers from the shirt tour came
in who I knew four years ago.
So I can just say that because there's
so many of them and we go back to my
house and we're by the pool table.
And Kristie you know my old girlfriend
comes out and I shouldn't say her name.
Well it doesn't matter
it's not her last name.
Still love you.
And she has puke breast and she took her
bra off and just had a T-shirt on there
sticking straight out and the girl just
casually walks over to her lips and
starts sucking it.
Oh and me and my friend Ali would
just like they're like holy shit.
And you know.
I mean.
Russell Peters always does that joke
about like acting like he's gonna jerk you
up as a joke.
We say we take care you date tough guy.
And I mean that is just so odd.
And it was sexy to a point and then one
of the girls wanted to go down the other
one.
That's right Julie line.
Imagine if there was so as many like
really openly bisexual men as there were
openly bisexual just
different it's different.
Well it's different because it's bullshit
because a lot of them aren't really
bisexual.
Some of them are.
For sure you are just a lot of women a..
I'm saying they're fake
and not an act for us now.
Zee Don't break my family and
there's no stigma attached to it.
No social stigma.
You know some girls genuinely like girls
of course but there's a lot of fake
lesbians out there.
We all know that.
I know the girls are in the porn
that our girls are all real.
I mean yeah yeah I mean all
that although a lot of them.
Yeah.
Not all those girls you
can't say most of us.
I mean if they if they're
not gay they tell you.
Well I'm not talking about girls that
are like into hardcore sex either.
I'm talking about girls like making out
with girls in bars and chilling out.
Well they don't actually do anything.
Oh yeah.
Yes a lot of that going on
when they're doing a fashion.
Well you ever hear of lugs lugs lugs.
It's a phrase in high school and
college girls use it's lesbian until
graduation.
No.
Yeah.
And like a lot some girls too.
Well I just I'm one of my
friend's daughters is a lug.
Really.
She said she's so going to be
a lesbian till she graduates.
Wow.
And then what happens graduates the cock.
I don't know.
I don't know what happens but I give
you that you'll raise your eyebrows.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
Wow.
Lesbian until I've heard gay for the
stay for guys are going into prison.
Oh really.
Yeah.
You never heard that.
No.
They go gay while they're in
prison only just gay for the stay.
Yeah well you never heard that Brian.
No we don't watch enough
Mexican gang movies.
You don't watch enough Mexican gay porn.
Settle down.
I don't think there exists.
Does it.
Yes.
Yeah.
You know because you're watching.
Oh it's oh I've tricked you a Jew
you into my less than obvious.
Well here.
Yeah.
Okay
I got you in a gay trap.
Felons gay spears.
Dominic Joseph thank you for having me on.
Always a pleasure my friend.
We got to do this more often.
Definitely.
We're back to playing pool at least once
a month it seems like I'm back after
the Fourth of July after did
the Atlantic City gig come back.
I'm taking a couple of days there.
Then we'll all be here
for at least a month.
Beautiful What are you What
are you doing this week.
What he got going on this week.
This week I'm doing a thing for all the
radio guys in Miami Beach like all the
disc jockeys.
It's called a boot camp
for all the morning hosts.
Oh yeah that's that'll be fun
because what do you what is it.
What do you do.
I just do standup.
I mean it is like a show.
I mean like well I'm the show just
to give them a break from all that.
It's like a convention.
Oh I see I see and then they hire
comedians to come and perform at the
convention.
Oh I didn't even know that this jockey's
have conventions like that you know.
I mean I'd heard about
it but I never saw it.
Why don't we have a fucking convention.
Why not.
What we should have a fucking man.
We need we we need a
death squad celebration.
That's what Montreal is like.
Well it would be then I'd
love hanging out with you.
Montreal is.
That's the short.
That's one one place.
That's that's what a jet like
celebration and gathering of comedians.
Yeah.
After a while I stopped doing it because
it was like it would kind of cost you
money.
You know like I if I spend like a week
and a half in a place I can't spend that
much time away.
You got it.
Yeah you're.
Well you know you created your own niche.
You're smart.
I mean you never let go.
That's so I'm surprised
you're going to Brazil.
Well I like working for the UFC too.
You know I don't.
I think I think you can do
more than one thing in life.
Yeah.
No I'm not happy when
I'm doing like only one.
I agree.
I told you I'm doing Raging Bull.
Next week when I got a one day
shoot I'm playing Joey Lewis.
Raging Bull too.
Yeah.
Now you know I know first of all I guess
Jake LaMotta must have all the rights
to to his obviously to his own life.
Oh because I don't know how
they could do it without him.
He knows that it's under his auspices
but like you know it doesn't seem like
Raging Bull to me without
the Nero and Scorsese.
But I heard the script.
The script was really good.
Michael boss who's doing it
who's director Zac Efron is uh
you know chasing beaver as
Spencer Pratt as you said.
Did you look it up.
Who's in it.
I think it's on.
That funny though.
One day with the.
Day at the Tropicana
one day raging bull too.
Yeah.
So this raging bull too What is it
with the is it like his later life.
I think it's an OK thing.
Yeah.
Please him.
I think.
Joe.
Joe Bologna.
It looks like there's a
guy named Joe Bologna.
You never heard John say it like that.
Well I mean William forced baloney.
The Bologna baloney.
It's like he didn't call a
baloney but below Italy's.
Yeah.
City.
There's this.
I know that Italy is a city but
that city and go fuck yourself.
That's baloney.
Hey take it easy John Hughes.
William Forsyth Joe Montana.
Joe Montana.
Oh Joe Montana the the Oh he's good at
famous actor he's a great actor Paul
Sorvino is in it Oh this
is like a legit cast.
Natasha Hendrix Well he's the chick from
she wasn't legit when I was just in it
so wasn't that it took away credibility
I had a Penelope and Miller.
Okay that's uh that is a very legit cast
there's a lot of people joining us see
my listed is this a DIY rare and they're
kind of bullshit is this I think it
does that a big guy did last week.
Maybe they don't want
a death squad boycott.
You'll be listed.
A man Dharma Rara.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
You must my Tommy voice.
You're still listening.
I'm unless you're in the game and you're
also listed right before that 4 pound
puppies which is cute.
I'm
really serious.
Damn you were on pound puppy in short
order so I don't want to Toro to ruin my
man paying guy image.
I was I was a beautiful
dog pound puppies I think.
Well yes you are the fraud princess.
Yeah I was.
You were here.
I was so beautiful I thought I was
a girl but I was really a tough guy.
Look up for a little bit of boom.
What was a what was my who was my father
and that like my owner Ted was like
some famous actor that used to wear you
which one of you dash I can't tell but
look at oh.
I think I'm the one with the.
Let's get some volume.
I never heard Bobby's
homeward power go dogs go.
I'll be a malamute song.
Bonus features include a lesson on.
Cops.
Yeah.
Well like Holy shit.
Hey Joe you got to make
a living all right.
That looks like it's designed
to rob children of their brains.
It sucks your brain out.
What.
What did you do that won last year.
I was you know I played a few
dogs and a few movies what a bro.
I I was in was the bobcat the barnyard.
Kevin deer Dukes the dog was the dog.
Yeah and you're also and never age
joke cartoons is the way to go.
Cartoons is amazing.
If you could be like a voice
the symptoms like Harry Shearer.
Yeah I mean Harry Shearer's rolling yeah.
He's been doing that forever.
You're on.
Dr. Katz.
Yeah it was the most yeah.
I was on the most.
I love it.
I love that guy.
Yeah.
John.
He's a hilarious comic
and knows the other one.
Hey Arnold.
I mentioned that earlier.
Yeah.
What was Hey Arnold again.
Hey Arnold was Gray's kid
with the football head.
Remember that hit like a football
head and he was he lived in it.
He lived in a boarding house.
He didn't have parents but
his grandparents and all
the people loved him and
took care of him.
And I was when I was Ernie
Potts demolition guy.
I forgot to level it today.
He wanted to level
everything that's Hey Arnold.
He's like Stewie but grown up.
Do you like doing like a
little kid shows and cartoon.
Oh yeah.
It's fun.
It's such a great contrast from
my lives in nightclubs you know.
Right.
It's fun.
Yeah.
I got to read it.
You'll be great at it man.
You do a lot of voices.
Yeah I could do something.
Voices.
The real Joe.
Okay.
I do them the real you know some kid
who was so dumb she goes I was duped the
dog and I was my DIY class I
took my dad one of my teachers.
His kid loved the love barnyard so I
took a picture of Duke and signed the fur
because you don't look like Duke
thinking you fucking idiot cartoon.
How old is the kid.
She was like 8 or 9.
Do
you call the 8 or 9 year old a fucking
idiot does she see a cute kid but my god
is a can't tell it's animated.
Damn I thank you for stopping by.
It's always a pleasure.
You're one of funniest comics of all
time and I'm proud to call you a friend.
Love your and powerful Dharma
where it can be found on Twitter.
It's two hours in the beginning.
Dom I are right to the beginning.
I r r e r a i r r e r a.
Don't fuck that up.
I r r r e r a follow him on Twitter I
promise he will use it as well as this
young relative will get I rarer to post
photos perhaps a car an account with
Instagram.
Brian.
We make this happen.
Never did.
What the fuck you saying son.
It's not that early Instagram right.
Instagram can eat.
Brian says Instagram can eat his dick.
You hear that Instagram.
Well I say you reach out
to Brian especially since
they're on my Facebook now.
Well so what.
I like Facebook.
Why do you hate Facebook.
Facebook is lame.
Rude dumping mean it's
also Facebook slime.
Yeah a blog.
This was life.
I don't know this mother
fucker on Facebook there's
nothing wrong with Facebook.
Bucks borrowed.
Be a hater.
MySpace isn't even boring.
How about that.
Brian you're a good kid.
Get it together.
So you haven't felt the league lately.
You don't like Facebook
as much like oh I don't.
Now I know it's already
turning into MySpace for me.
I like getting good at it you know.
Quite honestly I barely use it.
I use it a little bit forget.
I'll answer the occasional e-mail.
Dalia I love you.
Thanks to the fleshlight
go to Joe Rogan that night.
Click on the link enter in the
code a rugged save yourself time.
Percent thanks to 15 I.
Oh did I say 10.
Yeah.
No.
10 is the next one.
I should do these in order
where they should be at 14.
It should be OK.
God damn it.
We'll get on that.
Oh we'll get on it.
Thanks a lot.
Give people every week.
Just erase it my darling.
I think flashlights only good ones.
Just raise if I guess like some perv
trying to save 50 percent off every week.
Jacking off into fake
pussies then that's the end.
Show's over on a dot com codename Rogen.
10 percent off there.
Get some kettlebell Sun stacked
on some fucking meat sun.
Get yourself some some farmer strength.
All right you dirty bitches.
We'll see you next week.
We got a lot of people next week.
I got.
We're still trying to get in touch with
Josh Barnett but we got George Yosuke
willows next week.
Jim Norton next week and Jim Norton.
Yes powerful Jim Norden on the twenty
seventh and then on Friday we got Adam
squaw guy who is the writer director
producer of the movie the union that
cannabis documentary that
I was in many years back.
Holler at your boy.
See you dirty bitches next week.
Big kiss.
Love ya.